alors l'électronique sert à beaucoup de
choses y compris à tirer les numéros du
loto françoise on nous dira si c'est le
47 45 tout à l'heure l'électronique sert
par exemple à améliorer la qualité de
l'accueil dans les aéroports ainsi vos
billets d'avion vont bientôt changer
révélation de gérard jouany le nouveau
billet est un document cartonné unique
qui fait à la fois billets et cartes
d'embarquement il entrera en service à
air france à partir du printemps
avantage pour les passagers beaucoup
moins d'attentes aux guichets on peut
même retenir son siège en achetant le
billet pour les passagers sans bagages
on prévoit même des bornes automatiques
d'enregistrement qui vont accélérer
l'embarquement avantage aussi pour la
compagnie ces billets sont un
falsifiable on va ainsi stopper le
phénomène énorme de vol de billets
vierge
la plupart des compagnies européennes
vont venir progressivement à ces
nouveaux billets magnétique